as far as pootie glock 9 like is
everything kosher is it in the air like
how's the relationship with those guys
there's never no pressure like it was
it's not i don't got pressure on nobody
i don't got nothing with nobody i don't
got nothing going on with nobody does it
feel better to like
move like i feel like when you're in a
city like orlando that doesn't really
have like a national identity in hip-hop
like it's probably better if everyone
just kind of moves
together if that makes sense like the
way atlanta you know i feel like atlanta
a lot moves kind of
in the same direction like you all see
yeah you'll see the amigos and 21 and
gucci and everyone works together you
know what i'm saying
everybody worked together on that too
but it'd be like i don't know
taste some real [ __ ] though okay boom
down there's like
like okay boom everybody we everybody
start from the same spot whatever right
we at this level everybody at this level
and it's like boom
[ __ ] will see like damn
bro on the level up higher than me
damn he just went up another level
higher than me you see him saying
and go to hayton
so not lowkey they still like their
player like okay yeah
we dogs or whatever
but be hating loki
and that's just throwing [ __ ]
that's how [ __ ] we going down there
on some real [ __ ]
i feel like that happens a lot in a lot
of situations yeah but that's like
you know working together on it be like
damn
that should just be on a little bit i
don't even really want to get into
detail about this [ __ ] but you got you
get it i hear what you're saying it does
feel like in the smaller places like
i guess jacksonville is a great example
where it's like yo if everyone just
moved in the same direction and like
showed love
i mean jacksonville's wild that shit's
crazy down there but
it feels like in the smaller cities and
like it's a crab crabs in a bucket type
of mentality whereas opposed to being
happy for a peer of yours
yeah and being genuinely happy for them
instead you feel
some type of way because it's not you
yeah man that should be crazy
[ __ ] crazy